how's it going bros apparently that's a
freaking key right here and I didn't see
it I would you're a freaking idiot I
hate you don't say like that I'm your
buddy
we're French we make up I mean what
friends don't make out PDA with Hank are
you talking about there's something you
want to tell us all right
whatever let's just go ahead I agree
with you Stefano to spare the
awkwardness okay all right
finally some action all right put your
day or spano I read this wow so much
action please I need to help my patient
you seem like cleaner can ran into
Milledge following the valley with a
care chest a problem a run and handling
garnishing I followed him my help -
except doing instead I found myself an
empty room found a hatch in the corner
hoping it paid inside and I'm holding a
small pet I expected I'm Carol ash I
knocked
please come quickly what else what are
you doing here I can see you hiding
barrels don't hide from me alright don't
you dare get out of my house barrels you
disgust me
disgust me Baroness
wait there's got to be something more in
here than just a freaking note right
hey what's going on lamb don't [ __ ] with
me it's got to be something I mean come
on man
they can't just leave me with it now can
they sivanna
no it's impossible no don't they dare
oh wait we got no alone
well I don't know don't look at me like
that I don't judge me because I'm naked
but nothing funny you're naked
we should go to discharge with it this
way I'm seriously getting tired with
smut
it's so confusing is I go here the days
go dad I don't even know I'm spinning
look at spinning that's really what I'm
doing something crazy
are you happy okay
uh maybe something here no I don't know
a shed I don't even know what a shed is
come on I'm stuck in ho hold on I gotta
cheat okay we're back and I totally
didn't cheese or anything wow they
really hide things in this game for you
how am i loud I know there was something
in here I was just kidding with you I
have to leave Stephane um now I have to
put inside those boxes open the narrow
hatch ask will inside there was
something I didn't like about why I was
going because it was dark I am starting
to hate this mode because it's too
[ __ ] difficult for me after tonight
it's annoying like it can't find the key
couldn't find the hatch couldn't find my
penis anyway it's my penis wait what
okay whatever let's just go it started
off so good this [ __ ] fun now it's
this countess [ __ ] the walls closed
around me as I write I'm reading this
get out while you can
double Alex witness here resemblance the
man we know but not for foolishly when
she plays and stuff what does this
strange chemical large oil Persian
another cap of a I don't even know what
a cap is but
wait the walls are closing in on me that
mean I can
are they rally oh yeah are really
another puzzle
stop where's the stone tell me what
happened in here
I don't understand
get out while you can but I can't I
can't do [ __ ]
No
he's gotta be throw a rock somewhere or
something I don't know how I'd you you
like it
do you like that
you like when I throw you rap can we go
back in the hatch come on
really really guys it's [ __ ] custom
mod it's [ __ ] ass I hate honestly
obviously I'm gonna use this and then we
got to blow it up wow I'm so tired
frickin ah I did that I did that by
myself what are these doing here
oh no no fancy stuff okay maybe I can
bounce over them I don't dress yet I
can't not just up now now I got just
are they going nah does cooking yet oh
oh
or wet foot okay I'm just going I'm
going
oh wow what the [ __ ] man I'm just
kidding hey Mary [ __ ] I brought it
hey it wasn't me no sighs OH oh yeah I'm
going with you I don't wanna go that ah
I love breaking head you hit my head I
gave five I'm good
but you are loud now I said I'm fine I
jumped into the UI is described by hey
that's right he hit my balls
oh ah sorry left bollock Suzy sensitive
oh okay I need to touch your puppies oh
come on you're such a [ __ ] there's such
a [ __ ] I hate you make me be a [ __ ]
make me to lose my honour
man I'm seriously pissed
either she want from me I just want to
break down Sahel out of here
all right fine all right come oh no no
this is bad
oh this feet come out okay we're good
how we're not good Daniel
get the [ __ ] up it's not a dime time for
break dancing it's not time for break
dancing Daniel get up get up
Daniel get up I'm talking to you in the
bed say I thought you were German so
maybe you understood that
okay okay we're good
yeah a little good to the friend again
the TV team oh man so many boxes yeah
it's gonna have to move them that
because they hide freaking developer
hide stuff behind boxes
I hate boxes I hate boxes more than
anything I guess it barrels more barrels
feel like they're cooperating boxes and
barrels and everything okay you're then
at anything you just wasted my time
oh man I feel so drunk boxes Meister
share please show some respect all right
just chill out I know you're upset but
geez I don't know okay good we had the
key it's a heavy J even I know what else
does have a key that's right my penis
what you got a problem huh oh I hear
footsteps oh okay okay
hello hello how you doing hi anybody
tickle tickle tickle tickle
you like I don't yet all right fine I
won't touch you anyway okay keep on
going keep on Tralee ah oh you're ready
for this yes yes uh I had him done okay
what I didn't do anything I was just
checking his pockets what do you think I
was doing oh wow good
no no no why Scully I'm sorry I paid it
was we are taking our monthly best okay
fine I need some fauna in this place oh
man look at those dead bodies they're so
bad
they're like beyond that they're double
dead double kill net a same thing this
place this is where I came from right I
don't even remember
Oh
fine I'll try to remember better this is
typical Blaine I don't want to lose
waste my oil but whatever okay let's go
up here up in this creepy [ __ ] place
okay let's use the heavy key are you
freaking kidding me what do you want
from me
are you kidding me you have got to be
kidding me I'm not joking you're joking
it's not funny not funny okay we need to
go somewhere else apparently the game is
telling me to [ __ ] off this is really
where I came from I don't remember huh
hello
huh
hey bro what's going on here what are
you doing down there bro
it's so creepy
what I don't oh come on man oh my god
bro-bro do you want the key now what do
you say wallet is freaking penis why is
everyone in this game naked fine I'll
leave
I've been in the air come on
here
now
sup with this freaking thing so
disturbing I hate it I already ate it I
don't even know anymore that's where I
came from
I don't remember oh man
I don't want to go in here I'm not gonna
lie guys okay I will do it off king
kelana [ __ ] up a lot of ink about all
the okay fine I'll go here because
there's a line here and the dead bodies
mister leg and holy SH Kesha I need help
help me someone I can run in here holy
[ __ ]
can I get out
no I can't I'm screwed
I'm literally screwed I'm screwed
I got great pardon screwed in the back
come on
no don't trust that
I'm just gonna go on the heck out of
this hole
go up oh no oh
bowels oh come on barrels be fake I'm
sorry I hurt your feelings you don't
have to team up on me it's not fair just
too many against me
okay maybe it works the a we're trapped
by your friends'll trap I'm talking to
heaven and I'm afraid to sleep tonight I
James and stuff okay
ah this is nothing look good
this does not look Vinita be Anita ah
man
all right let's do this
am I really out of oil surely the things
have seen hair stumbled from a nightmare
the things I've seen the noise it's a
letter that just seems so unreal
and yet I continue to watch you for the
night surely I must be mad
descending in some godforsaken hole why
do I have a French accent I don't even
know all right keep on Charlie keep on
traveling tall and all the trollin
trollin trollin trollin what keeps
rolling uh-huh no problem it's so dark
it's so dark it's darker than my penis
that made no sense that made no sense
come on there's so many holes that's
what she said ha ha ha ok this one said
one okay we got a glass jar and some oil
all right let's see what else we can
find a niche dark place it's dark but
I've been in darker places I will
survive this place I am paid to buy I
can do this
no I'm Batman Radley Batman no you're
not
this is for can't pass for cuz I need a
staff key on plan it's really yeah like
I could work this is five hello five
how's it going in down here mr. fire
room number five Wow it goes down Wow
okay fine I'll go down I don't even care
oh oh no I know it's bad it's not this
too big for me I'm Susie scared
where the [ __ ] am i okay
yeah we're gonna go over here now guys
animatable actually I'm uh oh we got the
key okay
[Applause]
I don't even know anymore
nice doggie nice doggie nice doggie all
right we got what we came for
I hope at least but okay number five bad
news
got it got it water is always bad news
in this game son let's go up here see
what happens over here oh man huh huh oh
no I don't like that number
[Music]
he's gonna rape her for sure that's not
good for anyone except her I guess or
him
I don't know okay let's find two and
three and stuff for five I mean that kid
that's fine the other ones really quick
okay what is this
[Music]
oh wow I can go here
maybe the key works
all right oh we should've did
all right I gotta end it here guys I'm
gonna see you tomorrow
like and favorite than all that kind of
stuff and I'll be sure to keep giving
you guys videos this is not just freakin
creepy as hell I don't even know anymore
oh man look at these pictures I know my
toe all the [ __ ] great okay
[Music]
oh no no he's such an [ __ ]